the games have started
[Music]
and get is the bar The Bard is sharp we
have a plan to have plants he fails
he's charming and bikeable
oh God I could kiss you try it
Olga is a barbarian lives to fight foes
and everyone else
luckily you can't make her angry because
she's already angry
Simon is a sorcerer master of magic
[Music]
maybe I'm not saying it
is a druid he changes shapes on the
outside
zank is a paladin a warrior Associates
and he can afford to be polite
heal as well good sir he's interesting
Forge is a rogue trust him once shame on
you keep her safe you have my word trust
him twice I don't want to see him die
which is why I'm gonna leave the room
and then we have the red wizard powerful
and ruthless the last face you want to
see
and now you are ready to go out and see
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
you must have found a new Den did he eat
the last one
[Music]